Also zuerst einmal muss ich sagen,
dass ich sehr fasziniert
bin, hier zu sein,
und sogar virtuell habe ich diese
Diskussion, äh, mit Ihnen,
äh, und ich glaube, dass, wie Sie äh
zuvor erwähnt
haben, äh dieser Posthumanismus und all das
damit zusammenhängende äh Theorien also
ähm sehr äh
sind in unserem äh Alltag präsent
und ich denke, dass sie in Zukunft äh mehr sein werden äh so äh
Ich habe mich sehr für das
Thema äh Posthumanismus interessiert
äh und ich fing an
äh zu bekommen
ähm interessierter
ähm, als ich es mit meinem ähm Tutor
und meinem Vorgesetzten diskutierte und ähm mir wurde klar,
wie wichtig es ist und wie breit und
offen für neue Interpretationen es sein kann
und es tatsächlich sehr viel mit
ähm der Vergangenheit, der Gegenwart und der Gegenwart zu tun hat  Zukunft
ähm also
ähm Ich glaube, ich hatte eine erste Idee, ich wollte
ähm recherchieren, ähm, die Puppe, wie ich sie nenne
, also ist die Puppe so,
ähm, sie kann viele verschiedene Dinge sein, äh,
für mich ist sie eine Figur, sie kann eine Form
sein  kann ein Model sein eine Schaufensterpuppe
äh ein Spielzeug äh aber es kann auch äh
dargestellt werden  durch einen Posthumanismus
und ähm transhuman sind all diese verwandten
Theorien
ähm es kann ähm in diese
ähm Theorien übersetzt werden ähm als eine künstliche
Intelligenz ähm ein technologisches Wesen
ähm ein Android
ähm und es kann sehr viel
mit vielen verschiedenen
ähm verbunden sein ähm  lebende oder nicht lebende Organismen
ähm, also glaube ich, dass die Puppe eine
Art Werkzeug ist, ein Begriff, den ich verwende,
um ähm Realität und Fantasie zu kombinieren, ähm aber
auch
unsere gegenwärtigen ähm
philosophischen Ansätze und einen
posthumanen Zustand,
ähm  das kann sein, dass es noch wächst und
ähm, es kann sich in viele verschiedene Dinge verwandeln,
ähm, die hauptsächlich
in Fantasy und Science-Fiction diskutiert wurden,
natürlich,
ähm, aber ich denke auch, dass Technologie
ähm dieses Feld ist, das
mit Realität und Fantasie interagieren kann
ähm
,
ähm, ich wähle hier ein Bild
ähm von Julian Rosenfeld,
er ist eigentlich einer meiner Lieblingskünstler
ähm und ich glaube
ähm, dass es irgendwie
eine Verbindung zu dem beweist, was ich
vorhin über ähm Techno erwähnt habe  logie und leben
ähm also
denke ich dass sich unsere welt verändert ähm und
unser körper verändert sich auch ähm also müssen
wir nach neuen interpretationen unserer ähm
realität und unserem selbst und dem körper
ähm natürlich ähm unserem geist sowie
der wahrnehmung des konzeptes suchen  des
Körpers, ähm, ich denke, wird neu definiert, wird
ständig neu definiert,
ähm, und es sollte sein, ähm, alles um uns herum,
alles um uns herum ändert sich jeden Tag,
und Technologien dringen in unsere
Körper und Gedanken ein,
ähm, also ist
Posthumanismus ähm das perfekte Feld zum Diskutieren und
ähm und Ausprobieren  uns neu zu konfigurieren und
neu zu definieren
ähm, um auch in Zukunft besser angepasst zu
sein
ähm,
also denke ich, dass Posthumanismus Posthumanismus ist
und andere solche Theorien
können die Felder dieses bestimmten
Denkens über unseren menschlichen Zustand sein und
hin zu und hin zu einem
posthuman äh oder ein metallisch menschlicher und transhumaner
mit all diesen äh verschiedenen
Ideen, die durch seine ähm Bewegung repräsentiert werden
ähm ich eigentlich
ähm
als ich diese Diskussion beginne und ich ähm lese
Ihre Arbeit,
ähm, ich war sehr fasziniert von einem Satz, den
Sie verwenden, dass wir neue Konzepte brauchen,
um die digitale Lebenswelt und ihre
Ontologie
zu verstehen
und ich glaube, es hilft mir auch,
meine Interpretation der
digitalen und künstlichen und technologischen
Existenz
auszudrücken,
also konzentriert sich
meine Forschung,
äh, wie gesagt, auf das Konzept von
äh der Puppe,
die in verschiedenen
kulturellen und chronologischen Kontexten lag, äh, es
beginnt  Sagen wir, eine Puppe und Ma
und früher als das, wenn
wir die ersten Anzeichen von
äh der Puppe in prähistorischen Zeiten sehen,
äh, und dann sind wir zu äh,
automatisch und maschinell, äh, Roberts und IA übergegangen,
und wir können
all diese Entwicklungen von sehen  das konzept in
verschiedenen äh perioden und epochen äh und und
in verschiedenen
kontexten äh und ich möchte auf diese weise
seinen starken historischen und künstlerischen
wert hervorheben
äh der sich äh tatsächlich beweisen kann  Als
perfekt kann es bewiesen und
als perfektes Werkzeug verwendet werden,
um sich neuen Interpretationen zu nähern
,
äh, also, äh, der Punkt für mich wird durch eine
posthumanistische Theorie
äh und Transhumanismus und Metahumanismus
gesehen, die ich versuche,
kritisch zu sein  auf all dies und
diskutieren
äh und wie diese äh Figur äh übersetzt wird
in Fantasy und Sci-Fi
äh mit Betonung und Animation und
Stop-Motion sowie äh, was
eigentlich für mich äh Animation
eine Bewegung darstellt,
äh und aus der
wir uns bewegen  animieren, also ist es wieder ein perfektes
Feld,
um es irgendwie neu zu konfigurieren, was es
bedeutet, was
ein Wesen ist und was
Existenz wirklich ist
äh
da kommt eine Diskussion
ähm mit
ähm
verwandten Theorien wie dem ähm unheimlichen
Tal und solche
ähm schon äh
diskutiert und das ist wieder ein riesiges äh
Thema und das beweist diese
Verbindung
äh die eine unbelebte Figur mit ähm haben kann
echter
Mensch
ähm
also
für mich ähm dieses
ähm dieses Banksy
ähm
Disneyland ähm ist eigentlich
eine Art um anzufangen über
die ähm posthumane und transhumane Welt der Metal-
Menschen zu diskutieren
ähm also geht es nicht nur um die Figur,
sondern auch darum  die Welt, die
wir um sie herum aufbauen, um zu diskutieren
und
uns vorzustellen, wie diese
ähmneue
ähm
Ära und Welt und
ähm Philosophie, die wir versuchen,
in unser Leben zu integrieren,
ähm, tatsächlich in der Zukunft sein könnte,
ähm  Also noch einmal, wenn wir uns all
diese
ähm
posthumanen ähm oder oder postapokalyptischen ansehen, vielleicht können sie
sein, aber ich denke, dass diese Art von
Beziehung sehr eng ist und ich denke, dass diese
Grenzen der Postapokalyptik wieder
sehr überschritten werden können
ähm, weil äh ich glaube, dass
ähm Posthumanismus und Metahumanismus und
Transhumanismus ähm, sie sind offene Felder,
sie sind offen für Interpretationen,
ähm, und
sie sind miteinander verbunden,
sie können unser zukünftiges Leben darstellen, aber
auch,
ähm, sie können ein Beispiel dafür zeigen, was es ist
vielleicht
ähm
ich denke
ähm dass wir als Menschen eigentlich ich
meine wir sind eigentlich keine Menschen mehr wenn
wir so denken mit technik
äh jeden tag in unserem leben
ähm es wird klarer das wir nicht
alleine sind und es kommt darauf an  äh, welche Autorität
und wie und welche Macht
wir äh dem Ding geben, das wir tatsächlich
geschaffen haben,
ähm, sagen wir, diese technologische
Welt, diese technologischen Wesen,
die uns umgeben,
ähm,
also
denke ich, dass wir tatsächlich einen Übergang verlassen, ähm, wir sind
gekommen  bis zu einem Punkt, an
dem wir eine innere Reise brauchen,
um unsere Menschlichkeit zu verstehen und zu überdenken und
uns auf
die wahre Evolution
zuzubewegen, äh, die wir wahrscheinlich noch nicht
erreicht haben,
ähm, und dann kommt die Frage nach der
metahumanen, posthumanen, transhumanen
Perspektive und was wäre  Es ist die
Lösung
ähm
so für mich wie ich sagte
ähm vorher
ähm
die Tür ist so eine Interpretation
ähm um eine Art Recon zu konfigurieren und ähm und
über unsere Existenz nachzudenken
ähm also weiterzumachen
ähm ich wähle
ähm einen anderen  Beispiel, dass ich sehr
fasziniert war und ich eigentlich
äh äh weiter diskutieren äh
in äh in einer Arbeit, die ich gerade
schreibe,
ähm ist
ein Dokumentarfilm
äh von äh heißt Die Unsterblichen äh
Die ferne Seite
äh Südlicher Punkt Europas äh
was
ähm ist eigentlich
ähm über einige Leute
ähm was, dass sie Tschernobyl überlebt haben
ähm und ihre Wissenschaftler, die
ähm auf einer abgelegenen Insel entkommen sind
ähm und sie ähm repräsentieren einige, ich würde
einige, kein Thai, würde ich sagen, aber ich denke,
es ist hier klar, äh  Einige transhumane
Ideale,
ähm, aber auch ähm, sie repräsentieren dieses
ähm ewige Leben des Verstandes und der
Seele,
ähm,
also kommt für sie zuerst der Verstand und der
Körper ist entbehrlich,
ähm, es ist ein anderes Ich denke, dieses
ähm Beispiel ist eine weitere großartige
ähm-
Idee  äh und äh
Feld,
um äh über die äh
Evolution und Kontinuität unserer
Existenz zu diskutieren, äh
wie wichtig ist der Körper
als nur ein Körper als ein Objekt oder als
eine Form eine Form und wie sehr
er
äh viel mehr wird  äh  Bedeutsam,
ähm, wenn es um den Verstand und die
Ideen geht, die damit zusammenhängen
,
ähm,
okay, ich glaube,
ähm, bis zu einem Punkt der
eigentlichen Verbesserung des Verstandes,
ähm, wir können signifikante Ergebnisse haben, ähm, über
die Bedingung und über die Bedingung,
nicht zu leben  für immer ähm natürlich
ähm weil ich denke, wenn wir zum
Transhumanismus kommen
ähm
Vorstellungen vom ewigen Leben
ähm ich glaube das kann falsch interpretiert werden
ähm ich denke das für immer leben ähm ist nicht
zum Nachteil anderer ähm aber eigentlich
ähm geht es darum ähm leben zu können  alle
zusammen und
als
Wesen
ähm und
ähm
Nicht ängstlich, obwohl keine Angst vor Tod
und Krankheiten
ähm und nicht Verzweifelt auf der Suche nach ähm
etwas Besserem, etwas
ähm wie dem
Anti-Aging und äh
all den Schönheitsstereotypen,
sondern konzentriert darauf
, unsere Welt und unser Selbst zu erschaffen  als
Wesen
ähm besser
ähm,
also hier denke ich
ähm meine Königin gibt auch ein weiteres großartiges
Beispiel dafür, wie
ähm
versucht,
neu zu konfigurieren und neu zu definieren, ähm, was es
bedeutet,
ähm du zu sein, was ich bin  ein Wesen zu sein
äh und
äh und wieder sehe ich
äh diese Künstler
äh
Kreationen
äh und die Körper äh und die Figuren
, die er als Interpretation einer
anderen Interpretation
äh der Puppe einer Figur kreiert, die
sehr eng mit Realität und
Fantasie verwandt ist
ähm und es ist es kommt äh
dazwischen und als eine Möglichkeit, ähm alle Teile in
Einklang zu bringen,
ähm so
ähm, wenn wir über Transhumanismus und ähm diskutieren,
stoßen wir auf einen Begriff von äh perfekter
Fähigkeit
und Überwindung von Einschränkungen
und natürlich der Bedeutung von
Technologie
ähm und ähm, wie all dies helfen wird
,
um ähm etwas Höheres zu erreichen,
ähm, zum Beispiel Array zum Verkauf ist sehr
bekannt für seine
ähm Meinungen zu diesem Thema und die
Bedeutung des Transhumanismus
ähm für die Verbesserung der menschlichen
Verfassung ähm
äh,
wenn wir uns dem zuwenden, einen perfekten
Menschen zu einem perfekten Wesen zu
machen, kommen viele verschiedene
Diskussionen,
ähm,
und eines der
ähm klassischsten Beispiele  Ich schätze, es ist
der Frankenstein-Mythos, äh, und dann
, äh, äh, in den 1950er Jahren oder so, es ist dieses
Metropolis,
das eines der ähm
sehr klassischen Sci-Fi-
ähm ist
, das sehr viel mit
einem posthumanen
ähm Zustand zu tun haben kann  Beziehung und wie dieses
eigentlich dieses Gespräch, es hat
sehr viel früher begonnen und jetzt machen wir
weiter und versuchen und versuchen immer noch
, es in unser Leben zu integrieren,
aber es beweist auch diese Angst
, der wir immer noch gegenüberstehen und die wir immer
konfrontiert haben
ähm über Technologie und die Dominanz
ähm, was ich natürlich denke, wir
haben Angst davor, aber ähm, wir hören nicht auf
, ähm
, es besser zu machen,
ähm, und eigentlich ist es, denke ich, einfacher,
ähm, etwas
Technologisches besser zu machen, als
ähm a  menschliches Wesen Ich nehme an,
also ich ich pro Ich denke,
wir haben eine Möglichkeit, all das zu analysieren, indem wir
auf unsere Körper schauen. Unsere menschliche Natur
und dann unsere technologische Natur,
und dann werden wir in der Lage sein, zu
verstehen und
ähm  und
ähm all diese
ähm sim sehen  Ilaritäten und Unterschiede, die wir
mit der Evolution
anderer Wesen haben könnten,
und natürlich denke ich, dass der
alte Mythos von Prometheus ein weiteres Beispiel ist, ein
weiteres großartiges Beispiel dafür, dass
er sehr eng miteinander verbunden sein kann und
alles wie
Jahrhunderte beginnt  geht weiter und es
ist eine Diskussion, die
bis jetzt andauert, dass wir uns
äh
neuere Beispiele ansehen können. Tatsächlich ist dies ein
sehr aktuelles
äh-
Cover von vielen anderen
ähm, was
ähm,
eigentlich denke ich, was wir hier irgendwie alle
fragen
äh und was der Posthumanismus als Ganzes
zu beantworten versucht,
äh und natürlich sind das äh,
sogar wir können diese Figuren sehen,
die irgendwo zwischen einem Menschen und einem
technologischen Wesen oder sogar etwas
anderem liegen,
ähm,
also
wenn ich das sehe,
ähm, gehe ich  zurück und sage, dass
ich für mich in meiner Forschung
eine posthumane äh Puppe äh
metahuman Transgum vorstellen möchte und das
äh diskutiert und erforscht werden soll,
aber der Hauptpunkt ist, dass es
von den Beschränkungen von hu befreit ist  mensch und tier
menschlich und künstlich und all diese
grenzen äh es orientiert sich an neuen
perspektiven und richtungen
äh die ein zusammenleben zwischen äh
unterschiedlichen wesen sahen
äh
menschlich oder nicht
äh und die überschreitung traditioneller
äh grenzen äh
die puppe erscheint mir als schnittstelle
eine verbindung  von Arten äh Wesen und
Gattungen
ähm, die mit einem neuen zukunftsorientierten
ähm Denken ähm
und äh zeitgenössischen Darstellungen verbunden sind,
die über die Figur
und sie und das und das ganze Konzept
ähm diskutieren, das natürlich künstlich sein kann äh es
kann mit der Realität oder Fantasie verbunden sein
Mensch oder der Android-Cyborg
ähm,
also wenn ich
diese ähm Figur hier anschaue,
ähm,
es sind natürlich nicht ähm nur die
ähm technologischen ähm Wesen ähm, die verbunden sind, ähm Posthumanismus,
wie ich sagte, ich
sehe es als ein offenes Feld, das
ähm
es sein kann  kann, wo alles diskutiert
und neu arrangiert werden kann
und
äh
und wir sehen
äh das
durch Science Fiction und Fantasy
äh Geschichten
äh all diese
äh ich würde sagen äh Probleme  dass wir uns
stellen ähm wahrscheinlich
übertrieben dargestellt werden
ähm und am meisten und manchmal sagen wir
am korruptesten ähm oder vielleicht nicht
ähm
und eine missbrauchte menschliche Figur darstellen, eine
missbrauchte menschliche Natur
ähm
so
bin ich auch durch meine Recherchen  auch
sehr
ähmtief
beeindruckt und fasziniert von dem
Konzept der weiblichen Figur und wie
es durch die
Kunstgeschichte auf viele verschiedene
Arten interpretiert wurde
ähm und es kann auch ein großartiges Beispiel für
diesen Übergang und Wandel sein oder nicht und
Evolution
äh und ich möchte über die
Repräsentation des Weiblichen in
verschiedenen Spektren nachdenken
äh die vielen Gesichter
äh sie oder es kann
äh
von einem Menschen zu einem menschenähnlichen Wesen
äh eine Frau wie ein Android ein Cyborg
viele Gesichter äh das kann es sein  ein technologisches
Wesen ein Modal eine Schaufensterpuppe ein Kunstwerk
ein Subjekt oder ein Objekt
ähm es kann mit vielen verschiedenen
Genres in Verbindung gebracht werden, von Gothic äh mit einer toten einer tot
aussehenden Figur
ähm aber auch einer Puppe und einem Spielzeug
ähm
so  Wieder sind dies einige äh andere äh-
Darstellungen äh für mich äh der Puppenfigur
äh und es hat jedoch nichts
mit
äh einer Frau oder einem Mann zu tun,
äh, aber all diese
äh sind irgendwie
neu arrangiert und
es gibt eine ganze Diskussion darüber,
wie sie '  wir werden in zukunft
ähm
und und wie und wie es jetzt
läuft wie wir einen mann oder eine frau sehen und ähm und
wie und wie diese in zukunft äh
diskutiert werden wie auch äh
und dann kommt
äh auch äh ein äh  tolles Beispiel für mich äh von
äh einer posthumanen
äh Idee
äh das ist
äh Alexander McQueen
äh ein Künstler für mich äh wie ein
Modedesigner ein Künstler er irgendwie perfekt
äh
verbunden
viele verschiedene Aspekte der Realität
äh er kombinierte das Tierreich und
Das menschliche Königreich
ähm, während es dieses ähm kreiert,
entwirft diese Stoffe,
damit ein Stoff auch ein weiteres großartiges
ähm-
Beispiel dafür sein kann, wie wir unseren Körper definieren
und was wir tragen oder nicht
tragen,
damit der Stoff so ist,
dass wir diesen König I nicht wählen können
aber alle alle Teile von o  Unsere menschliche
Existenz ist wichtig, denke ich, in der
Diskussion über die Figur und wie all
diese eine Existenz schaffen.
Ähm, also hier
ähm, wähle ich,
ähm, diese
Mutationsfragen zu stellen, also ist es eine Mutation,
ähm, was wir auf diesen Bildern sehen,
ähm, ist es eine Mutation von  Unsere menschliche Natur
ist, dass wir uns in diese Richtung bewegen,
aber ich denke schon
, wenn ich es nicht weiß, muss ich
sagen, was wir in diesem
Schuh sehen  Also ist es eigentlich ein
Paar Schuhe, die Rapssamen in den
Boden
pflanzen, was bei dieser Wiederbelebung der
Natur
hilft, in solchen Gegenden wie
Fukushima oder dem Tschernobyl-Gebiet
, und da kommt diese Diskussion, die
sich
auf Kunst und Menschlichkeit und das Humane und
das bezieht  Tier
ähm auf dem anderen Bild
ähm und all das, was irgendwie
miteinander verbunden ist, mit unterschiedlichen
Verwendungen und unterschiedlichen Interpretationen, aber
es kommt alles zu einer posthumanen Perspektive, denke ich,
ähm,
die äh signifikant ist und m  Oves zu
dieser Folie
ähm wo wir sehen können
ähm eine andere Art von
ist es eine Mutation ist es
ähm
was wir brauchen ähm ist es transhuman
wird es eine Zukunft
ähm
wird es nur für Leute sein ähm
sagen wir wer
ähm,
haben
ähm einen Teil, einen Arm oder ein Bein verloren, oder
werden wir es in Zukunft sein, wird es
ähm,regelmäßig sein,
ähm, es hat mit Verbesserung zu tun
, die uns besser macht,
ähm,
also
sehen wir wieder eine Art Beziehung  aber zu
diesen technologischen
ähm
und
ähm dieses Bild auf der anderen Seite,
das viel älter ist,
ähm, aber es beweist wieder diese Verbindung, ähm,
und von einem Automaten, den
wir bewegt haben, sind wir zu vielen
ähm verschiedenen und
bedeutenden Entwicklungen
übergegangen, die uns tatsächlich helfen können
ähm
werden vielleicht besser oder nicht
so
ja wieder dies sind einige Beispiele dafür, wie
ich die posthumane Puppe sehe
ähm es kann wieder sein äh es kann
mit vielen verschiedenen Mythen in Verbindung gebracht werden Geschichten
Geschichten ähm in der Filmanimationsliteratur Ich denke,
es ist voll von Beispielen dafür
um eine Puppe, die
um
re sein kann  geschaffen und aber es enthält die gleiche
Grundidee einer Figur, eines Charakters,
der viele verschiedene Dinge sein kann,
und schließlich denke ich, dass es eine
dichronische Bedeutung hat und es ist und es ist
auch ein mehrdimensionaler Begriff,
also
für mich,
wie gesagt
ähm, ein wichtiger
ähm Teil der Forschung bezieht sich auf
Posthumanismus und den Begriff, den ich
von der Tür
ähm in Animation und Stop-Motion verwende, also denke ich
, dass die ganze Diskussion auch
mit diesem
ähm zonger zusammenhängt, was die Animation ist
Stoppen Sie Bewegung, weil
wir über Bewegung und Bewegung diskutieren und über
Automaten und Androiden und andere
technologische Wesen und Technologien sprechen, und
ich denke, Animation ist ein großartiges Feld,
ähm, diese Art von
ähm,
ich denke, dass es all diese
also den Dollar, umfasst  Ein Feld, das darauf hindeutet,
wie wichtig die Bewegung ist, äh, ihre
Definition ist sogar mit der Bewegung verwandt,
ähm,
und
ähm, auch
Animation, ähm, ich denke, sie gibt
ähm die ultimative Antwort,
und wir versuchen zu animieren
und zu geben  Das
Leben einer Figur,
ähm, es kann eine Zeichnung sein, aber es kann auch
ähm, eine Marionettenfigur sein, eine Stop-Motion-
Puppe,
ähm, also denke ich, es ist ein großartiges Feld, um
ähm über Posthumanismus zu diskutieren, ähm,
während ich mich bewege  on
äh ich möchte
äh erwähnen
äh zwei sind sehr wichtige
äh Themen äh das ist Anthropomorphismus und
Persönlichkeit äh
durch diese Beispiele auch
äh wir können
äh
eine menschenähnliche menschliche Ähnlichkeit
sehen äh wir können Objekte sehen wir können
Kunstwerke sehen
ähm
das versuchen sie menschliches Leben nachzuahmen
äh das versucht eigentlich äh ein
technisches Wesen
auch und dann kommt die
Frage was macht einen Menschen was
macht einen Menschen aus was macht uns eigentlich
minderwertig oder  Nicht
ähm, was uns besser macht oder nicht,
was uns Menschen macht,
und ich denke, dass diese Zahlen
versuchen,
ähm dieses Ding zu beweisen, Grenzen zwischen
ähm echt und künstlich belebt und
leblos, technologisch und natürlich,
ähm, also wie ich schon sagte, ähm über den
Stoff und die Haut  Das  Ich
denke, das ist ein weiteres Beispiel, das beweist, äh, dieser
neu geordnete Körper und die Veränderung und die
vielen verschiedenen Aspekte, die einen
anderen Körper erschaffen können, äh, sie können nachbauen,
und sie können
, äh, einige einzigartige, äh, Figuren und Formen
und Gestalten,
ähm, und hier,
ähm, so eine davon machen  Meine
ähm
letzten äh Recherchen waren
die Anatomiepuppen und
ähm und wie ich äh kriminelle Puppen nenne, das
ist
ähm das kommt von äh der Analyse von
äh Tod und äh Gothic und wie es
über die Jahre
und
äh Jahrzehnte äh und dargestellt wurde  Jahrhunderte
ähm in verschiedenen Darstellungen
und ähm
und ich denke, dass diese beiden Beispiele
auch sehr eng
mit der Idee eines posthumanen Wesens
ähm und einer posthumanen Tür, wie ich es nenne,
ähm verbunden sind, und hier sind wieder einige ähm verschiedene
ähm Beispiele  äh wo
äh wo ich versuche äh den Körper zu sehen und äh
live und der Anime orientiert sich an
der Recherche zu diesem
mehrdimensionalen und transformativen
Begriff der Puppe, der äh Plastizität
und
äh und das hohe Simulacrum Elem hat  ent
auch, also ist
es äh für mich, es war
äh großartig, äh, es war großartig,
diese Anatomie-Türen zu betrachten und dann
diese anderen charakteristischen Beispiele zu betrachten, auf die
ich mich beziehen und
sehen konnte, dass diese beiden sehr unterschiedlich,
aber eigentlich sehr ähnlich sind
und  Dies ist eine weitere Diskussion, ähm,
wieder hoch,
weiter zu allen Vorschauen,
ähm, über
die Bonuserweiterung und die Macht, ähm,
und wie es geformt werden kann,
ähm, wieder wie
etwas anderes, etwas Einzigartiges,
etwas, ähm, das entweder menschlich,
menschlich oder ähm
über Mensch ist  oder es kann einem
posthumanen Ideal nahe kommen,
ähm,
und wieder erwähnte ich den
Frankenstein-
Mythos,
ähm, ähm, und da oben, ähm, da oben
gibt es ein Beispiel für den letzten
ähm Cronenberg-Film, ähm, ich denke, ähm, er
Der Cronenberg als Regisseur ist ein
weiteres großartiges Beispiel dafür, wie er
über eine
posthumane Perspektive und den Körper diskutiert, und da
kommt auch der Körperhorror dazu,
also
denke ich,
um es
irgendwie zusammenzufassen, wie ich das kann
Ich sagte, die Puppe ist eine sehr breite Fülle, die
offen für Interpretationen ist und
alles verändert,
umgestaltet und dekonstruiert,
ähm, sie kann alle ähm Existenz vollenden, äh
, vergessen wir nicht, dass die Puppe im
Laufe der Jahrhunderte auf verschiedene Weise existiert, äh,
und sogar eine Puppe, äh, pflegte, eine zu begleiten
Person eine tote Person in ihren Gräbern in
der prähistorischen Zeit
ähm, also gibt es eine sehr breite Etymologie
des Begriffs
ähm seitdem hat es eine andere
Form gesehen Spectrum Summers Realitäten
Fantasien
äh vom Automaten der Android ein
Zombie ein Vampir, mit dem sie alle
verbunden sein können  äh der Begriff Puppe
äh als eine Figur
äh der Science Fiction oder äh Fantasie
äh, die tatsächlich
äh mit äh Realität und Technologie verbunden sein kann äh
ich denke
äh es können äh viele Herangehensweisen
an den Begriff sein, die seine Komplexität
und Essenz insgesamt betonen
äh  Ich denke um die Begriffe Körper und
Körpermodifikation und
Körperdekonstruktion und Transformation und
Mutation herum
und habe versucht, sie durchzudeuten
eine posthumane Perspektive, um das Menschliche zu
verstehen
und zu überdenken,
die Menschheit, das Menschliche und
die menschliche Natur
und die ganze Welt, die uns umgibt.
Ich denke, die Puppe ist ein Werkzeug für
eine posthumane Untersuchung und ähm
Überdenken, äh, es hat viele verschiedene Gesichter, äh,
und es kann in Zukunft noch viel, viel mehr haben,
äh, also noch einmal, das sind einige Beispiele, äh, noch, äh,
über den Körper,
äh,
und
all die verschiedenen
Seiten und Interpretationen,
äh,
und wie
Technologie darin integriert ist,
und  da kommen natürlich äh die großen
äh Ideale der Unsterblichkeit
äh und all diese äh Suche nach ewigem
Leben äh
und dann ist das wieder äh oder für mich ist das alles
miteinander verbunden
äh ein Cyborg und eine anatomische äh Venus
das ist äh eine anatomische Venus eigentlich
ähm, das war
ähm, das ist lebensgroß und aus
Spazierwegen gemacht,
ähm,
es ist einer dieser Kadaver,
die uns irgendwie ähm dazu bringen,
über die äh Runde auf Leben und Tod nachzudenken,
und natürlich ist es kein
Beispiel für ho  w
eine Person sieht äh aus, wenn sie tot ist oder
und
ähm und ja, und ich versuche, eine
Verbindung herzustellen
zwischen diesen technologischen Figuren
und der Anatomie, und dann
ähm, um zu
diesen
ähm
Modellen hier zu kommen,
ähm, die
ähm passend sein können, irgendwie
den Tod repräsentierend
ähm  auf unterschiedliche Weise,
und ich denke, dass ähm die Körperweltausstellung
eines der
ähm sehr charakteristischen Beispiele
ähm ist, dass wir sehr wild wissen können, dass
sie irgendwie
ähm diesen
Tod repräsentiert und äh und Technologie und wie
Kryonik oder andere Techniken in
Ordnung verwendet werden  um das Leben zu bewahren oder oder es
als ein Kunstwerk zu machen
ähm
also
ich denke
ähm
das sind mehr Beispiele und und ich denke
aber ich
habe ich habe ich habe keine Zeit mehr ich denke
ähm
also
ich denke das würde ich gerne tun
schließe mit diesen fragen
äh und denke über sie nach und diskutiere äh und
äh dieses äh auch ein Zitat äh von Donna Haraway äh
und ein letztes
äh, das ist diese äh äh
helle
äh Installation von äh shiota Shahara Ich bin mir
nicht sicher, ob ich es bin  aussprechen  richtig
ähm und immer wieder äh über den
posthumanen metamenschlichen und transhumanen äh
Zustand nachdenken